warzone streamer zealander has been
banned from the recent
warzone twitch rivals tournament now
he's a big name within the warzone scene
and a popular streamer
so he must have done something really
bad for this to happen
right well it appears that for twitch he
crossed a line
a line that has sparked a lot of fierce
debate and resurfaced one of twitch's
oldest mysteries because zee laner
cosplayed
as doctor disrespect on stream and
appears to have been
banned from playing in the tournament
because of it
i hope you're ready for this one
[Music]
okay then i am as eager as you guys are
to get into another insane
twitch moment but before we do just make
sure you are subscribed
to the score esports that way you'll
never miss a video
just like this one in the future all
right so before we jump into z
laner and dr disrespect let's quickly
talk about the warzone twitch rivals
tournament because
it is big bigger than your average
twitch rivals event
this year alone the war zone tournaments
have had some pretty
massive prize pools that rival even
mainstream esports events
in january 2021 the doritos bowl
tournament dished out a whopping 230
500 in prize money with the winning trio
taking home
45 grand but in the tournament on july
20th
one big streamer was not present one of
warzone's biggest names zealena was told
he was
ineligible to participate now it's a bit
of a typical twitch situation we have on
our hands here as twitch have not said
anything
publicly about this and zealander was
the one to break the news through a
tweet which also shows him wearing a
very recognizable
mullet and sunglasses combo now for
anyone who doesn't recognize it that's
the famous dr disrespect look which
zelena used as a cosplay during a
different warzone twitch rivals event
the month before
we had to put a little bit of respect on
somebody's name someone that we all may
know
that can't really do this himself over
here but we're gonna be doing it here
today for him
the stream went fine he didn't hear
anything from twitch the problem only
came when he tried to enter his next
twitch rivals warzone tournament
so before we get into why he was banned
let's very quickly talk about
why he was dressed up like this in the
first place
basically zeelena and dr disrespect are
proper good mates
and it's safe to say that the two of
them are quite often each other's
biggest fans
two other players left alive one goes
down
ladies and gentlemen one more on the map
and just like that
game time baby let's go
let's go doc but ever since twitch
banned dr disrespect
in june 2020 he's not been able to play
alongside zelena as
often like when he was banned from
playing in the toronto ultra tournament
in february 2021. i'm still gonna be
playing in the toronto ultra tournament
but doc
is unfortunately not going to be i'm
getting lots of messages right now sorry
about that
listen he's not allowed to play i got a
message back from the organizers from
toronto ultra and call of duty they're
the ones putting the tournament off and
they said
that doc is not allowed i'm assuming it
has to do with his twitch band i
messaged doc right away and i was like
bro is there any magic you can pull
anything you can do
and he said unfortunately not like it's
weird that they're not letting me play
in this thing
the pair both stream on youtube now and
while this is a personal choice for c
laner it's kind of a necessity for
doctor disrespect since the twitch ban
and this is probably a good time to
remind you guys that we
still don't know why dr disrespect was
banned from twitch
twitch hasn't said anything other than a
generic statement and dr disrespect has
always maintained that nothing was
ever explained to him and then have that
taken away from you
and to not know why and to not know
anything about it
not to be told nothing boom taken
grabbed everything we built all the eggs
in one bucket
boom taken away so as a friend of doctor
disrespect
zelena clearly isn't a fan of his twitch
ban
and although dressing up as him on
stream was clearly just a meme
it could also be seen as a bit of a
statement he knew it would turn heads
and wasn't trying to hide what he was
doing
at all in fact he went pretty hard
if he wanted twitch's attention well he
certainly got it the stream where zelena
cos played as dr disrespect was
actually the only time he'd ever
streamed on twitch before the tournament
ban
he did do two separate streams that day
for the same tournament but essentially
he streamed one time one time on twitch
and received this punishment for
essentially wearing a fake mustache and
mullet
like what this led a lot of people to
assume that the cosplay
was what got zee lane at the ban the
twitch had sat on this
for a month and didn't tell him until
the day
of the tournament zelena took to his
youtube stream later that day to explain
more about the situation day of the
tournament
i receive a message saying zee laner is
not eligible to compete today
and they had nothing else to say no no
further
no further reasoning why and it's kind
of funny
because there are other people that are
involved in this tourney that are
also not full-time twitch streamers
now the question a lot of you guys
probably have right now is okay
but why did he get banned from playing
in the tournament why is dressing up as
dr disrespect worthy of that
well the reason may also involve doctor
disrespect
in september 2020 three months after his
twitch ban he took part in a tournament
called
vic stars war zone showdown now during
the tournament dot disrespect ended up
in the same lobbies as some big names
who were streaming on twitch at the time
crimsix nadeshot even he is the
d-o-double
g the dogfather himself snoop dogg
now they didn't mute dr disrespect while
playing with him which
technically meant he was appearing on
stream and in twitch's eyes
circumventing his twitch band of course
it's unlikely that these streamers were
intentionally trying to give dr
disrespect his platform back
on twitch but those rules are in place
for situations like this
now the offending parties weren't banned
from twitch but one twitter user did
notice that twitch
had appeared to have updated their
suspension policy with a clarification
they said we understand that there may
be instances where suspended users
appear on your stream due to
circumstances beyond your control
but we expect you to make a good faith
effort to remove them from your
broadcast
mute them or otherwise limit their
interactions with your stream
the timing and details of the statement
seem to have come
as a direct result of what had happened
twitch was reminding everyone that if a
band user appears on someone's stream
they too run the risk of getting whacked
with the ban
so what does this have to do with
zealander then well the speculation
is that by dressing up in dr disrespect
lightness and shouting him out he was
giving a platform of sorts to a permaban
user
like i say this is all just speculation
because it's difficult to see
what else the elena could have done
wrong but let's quickly take a look at
twitch's use of the word
eligibility when it comes to tournaments
for their smash.gg event in march 2020
they included a list of criteria that a
player
must reach in order to qualify for the
event it said a player must be a twitch
partner or affiliate
and also broadcast modern warfare for a
minimum of 10 cumulative
hours on twitch achieve 20 total wins in
battle royale
and earned 500 total kills in battle
royale when a twitch community manager
was asked to clarify the eligibility
requirement on twitter
they said that a streamer must be a
twitch partner or affiliate
being good standing with twitch and the
publisher or developer
like i've said before zelina primarily
streams on youtube so he's not a twitch
partner but he is a twitch affiliate
as for the criteria from other similar
tournaments it could be that
maybe he didn't meet them it's hard to
tell though and zelena certainly thought
that the whole thing had more to do with
the cosplay than anything else
it was a meme it was meant to be a
friendly
meme that no joke even if twitch was to
see it
they would maybe even possibly chuckle
regardless of
everything that has happened over the
last you know you guys know that you
guys know you guys know
uh with thoth and without any
clarification from twitch that leads us
with a conclusion
that this cosplay was enough to bar him
from the tournament
that his costume and impressions were
enough for twitch to step in like this
as with a lot of twitch's recent
decisions around banning on twitch
this just leaves us with more questions
than answers streamers already knew they
can't have banned users appearing on
their streams
but now they'll be aware that they can't
really do impressions of them either
especially dr disrespect
gnarly he's just out and out of there
like buddy was gone
like no no one even knew where he was
you know
pretty [ __ ] bad pretty scary though
never